Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to "The Joy Of Creation: Reborn".
Now I have had, the WORST time, trying to get this video to you.
Let me explain how bad this morning has gone.
I got up at 5am this morning because I wanted to record this video and get it for 8am
and I was gonna do it and I was gonna beat it
and everything was gonna be fine and everything WAS going fine.
I was learning the map, I was learning everything about Chica, I was learning how to beat her.
And it got pretty easy, and I actually memorized every location of the page.
And I did this, because if you beat all of the animatronics,
you get a special secret bonus ( OH SOUNDS FUN )
that I'm gonna show you guys in a little bit.
(Distraught) But at the end of the bonus,
it just closes the game.
And that may not seem like a bad thing,
but a little behind the scenes on Let's Plays:
if you're recording, and I'm not recording in 'windowed mode'
I'm just hooking into the game directly.
If it closes, without me stopping recording,
there's like a 50/50 shot of it just corrupting the file.
So I've been recording for two hours!
And that chance of corruption goes UP!
The longer you've been recording, so
I lost it.
And I could recover it,
but it usually cuts off the last, like, 10% of the video
which was the bonus.
So...
THEN I went do it AGAIN
and I was trying to play Chica again
and I thought I LOSING MY MIND
because I was wandering the woods and there's NO PAGES!
'CAUSE ONCE YOU BEAT IT, THE PAGES ARE GONE
AND YOU HAVE TO RESET THE GAME TO DO IT AGAIN!
So I have had-- I am so sorry that this video is so incredibly late,
that things have been off-schedule because
I've also been working my own, Matt hasn't been able to edit for me
for like 3 weeks, so I've been doing everything
with the trips, and the other projects that we've been working on.
So, I have been BURIED under work,
which is why I got up at 5am, 'cause I had to work late last night
and I didn't have time to record
and then I gotta get up early, and I was going to be totally on schedule and everything was gonna be fine
BUT EVERYTHING THAT COULD GO WRONG
HAS
GONE
WRONG!!!
(soothing elevator music)
*sigh*
But!
What I'm gonna do...
Is I'ma--
Oh, hang on--
I'm'onna show you guys
this bonus, and then I'm going to reset everything
and beat Chica again
so that you guys can see the proper way to do it.
And it's relatively simple, so--
HI GUYS!
HOW YA DOING, BUDDIES?
Oh, I love you guys so much,
you've been so good to me
and all that jazz...
*loud sigh*
I just wanna relax with you guys, but I know that I can't.
Uh oh. Well, welcome to the real party everybody.
Thanks for being here.
And If you look to your right, you'll see a door that leads to nightmares.
So...
This is the special bonus and you go into this weird hellscape
that kinda looks like the bottom of Subnautica in that lava cavern
where supposedly the, uh, the Sea Emperor is gonna be or the Sea Dragon
or I'm not 100% sure which giant monstrosity is gonna be there
but, it's gonna be big and it's gonna be evil, just like the area in here.
And if I recall...
AHHH FUCK YOU!
Ok. Got 'em.
Alright, it's cool!
I got my defense up just in time!
Everything's fun and fantastic and free.
And if you go over here, you'll notice-
Boink!
Ohhhhhhh it's still in HELL.
Still a perpetual landscape of HELL.
Oh, man.
I tell ya, if--if this--if this crashes again
I'm recording in Windowed Mode, I'm very much meticulously making sure
that I'm recording in the proper way
that this is gonna work 100%.
Because man, it has been a morning of hell
and I've got so much more work that I need to do
but you guys come first-
Hey! What's that behind you?
(Muffled deep laughs in-game)
(Mocking laugh)
I've got such an incredibly long day ahead of me, but
I'm just, you know, I--I--I--I'm not begrudging doing Let's Plays.
Like I'm not saying that, but for some reason
you'll occasionally, in everything you do, no matter what; art, school, and--like jobs, whatever.
You'll have one of those days, where everything that is bullshit in the world
will culminate, all your arch-nemesi will get in one room-
Woh...
Oh yea, I forgot. All your arch nemesi will get in your one room like this:
HI FOXY!
Phantom Foxy, Digital Weirdo Foxy, some kind of Foxy derivative that I don't know about...
and they will just DESTROY YOUR EXISTENCE.
Where am I going?
Oh, hello.
My flashlight doesn't seem to work, I don't know why I even have it out.
Hellooo! Hiii!
I think this is--
(Distorted noise)
C͉̗̠̽́ͪͥ͞ȯ̈́̍̋͌͏̯͍͚̝̜̻m̢̺͓͙̱̣͓͔̹ͭͣ̍͐̓e̥̘̲̔́̓͊̔̕͞ ͫ҉͈͉̞̖̖͇̖͎͜ͅb̪̤͎͙͉͔̽͒ͭa̤̻̫ͦ̾̈͆̆̎ͭͩc̭̜͇͈͎͛͑̚͝ͅkͤ̐ͧͧ̑ͫ͒̂͟͏̘̦̗̭̮͍̞ ̵̴͔̪̻̣̜̠͌̏́̈́ͥ͆͋͆̏l̛̬̪̜̬͙̪̱ͨ͛̄͑̎͛̚a̩̪̻͐ͣ̂̈̿t̜̼̺̻͚̰ͫͥ̄̓̄̈͘̕͜ͅe̢͖̩͇̘ͪ͛̄̑ͭr̛͕̲͖̖̯̝̋̔ͪ̍ͭ͌ͪ̃.̡͂҉͉̪͙̫̲.͎̦͈̿̅̏̅ͯ̈́͋ͩͩ.̶̯͇̿̀̚
Oh...
And there you go!
Game just closes on you like that.
Cooool right? Ok.
*sigh*
So that was the special secret
and now the developer's gonna be working on the game in full.
But what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna load the game back up,
and then I'm gonna show you guys...
everything...
on beating Chica.
So I'll be right back.
Ok! So now I'm going to erase my progress,
which is always a fun thing to do.
BOINK!
Yep, boink, boink.
What do I-- oh!
I CAN ERASE THEM SELECTIVELY!
OHHHHHH THANK YOU!
OHHH I DIDN'T KNOW I COULD DO THAT!
Ohhhh I can just play Chica again!
Ohhhh I don't have to do them all-- I wasn't going to do them all anyway
but now it actually looks like I don't have to do them all.
Ohhhhh thank goodness. Ok!
So with Chica, it's-- it's a-- it--
Everything does not randomly go different places.
All the pages are in the same place,
at least I hope so, unless it changes again, I have no idea. But...
I--the pattern is relatively simple because it involves a lot of staying on the path
except for the very beginning...
and then the very end.
And some point in the middle.
But for the most part, everything that you need is generally in a similar area
to where you spawn in at.
Now, I didn't spawn where I usually spawn, so I got to worry at myself
I think there's probably a page.... where am I?
Ah dammit, of course I'm getting turned around.
I wouldn't be able to show you guys exactly what to do-
Uh oh...
Let me just die to, uh, spawn-
OH HELLO
(Loud distorted scream)
AHHHH MY FACE!
(gibberish babbling)
Alright. Ok, here we go. This is usually the typical spawn that you'll get
and like the most often
so you get this one first, which has like some Japanese writing.
And you CAN run. Like, that was uh-- that was a misconception from me,
you can- you can run, literally, all you want.
And she won't mind, all you gotta do is make sure you look at her every once in a while
to appease her ego
and then everything will be hunky-dory after that!
No, I--I got turned around again, where the hell is the second one?
God dammit.
I'M A BAD GUIDE!
Aw man, fuck this.
Where the fuck is it?
What the fuck? Are you kidding me?
Oh, there it is, ok. I got it.
Alright. Sorry about that, I-I just keep on getting turned around
(high-pitched) JUST GRAB IT!
Grab it! What the fuck, grab it!
Fuck you! What the fuck was that?
Why is this game dicking with me?
Why am this game dick with me?
Ok, you get that one, you get the dogey-doge
you get the dogey-doge over there, keep looking at her
you get this one over there
and BAM, you got 4 right off the bat.
Now you just--from here on out, you can just kinda follow the path,
going round and round until you find everything you need
and most of them are either on this path that you're on, or,
they're very quickly off-shoots of the path.
So, coming up here we're gonna reach a light that's another landmark
that you can use. The only light that's actually
adjacent to the fence is actually kinda pointing towards the next page that you need, so
as long as you don't get turned around here, if you go perpendicularly out,
not quite to the path, but if you go perpendicular out...
from there-- Oh shit.
Ah, there it is! There it is, sorry.
Got a little turned around. You grab this one,
you can get that and then you need to get back on the path
you can scoot ahead a little bit, you don't have to go right back to the light.
Go back to the light if you need orientation,
'cause it can lose ya.
And then the next one is right on this tree over here,
and then you just follow the path continually
you'll get to the page that's on the fence.
And then you'll be in the general area for everything else.
Now, the misconception that I had
is every time I loaded up the game,
I kept getting these pages on the lamp posts,
and those pages on the lamp posts,
there's only like three of them.
Or maybe even two of them.
So, when I loaded up the game,
I didn't know exactly where I was
so I thought there were like five on the lamp posts,
but that's not true.
Here's the one on the uh, the fence here
This is the only one on the fence.
There's only one on the fence,
there's only two or three on the lamp posts,
and it all generally doesn't go anywhere.
So,
when you round the bend after this one,
you'll come to a path,
if you go to the right, there's a tree in the middle of the thing here
and there's nothing that way.
So you know that's a way you don't go.
And then if you round the bend here,
you pass this light,
you go...
Uh, for a ways off, until you reach another..
Either another lamp post, or another branching path. I can't remember which one comes up next.
I think it's a branching path.
Oh no, it's a lamp post.
Ok, so this lamp post also has a page
and then there's only two left.
And so the last page...
is actually if you take the next branching path,
it goes up to a dead end.
WHOA!!
I looked at ya,
don't be sassin' with me!
So if you over here,
there's a dead end.
But it does have a lamp post on the end of it
and you grab this one.
So there's a total of three on the lamp posts.
And then you wanna go back
the other way
to the other end,
which also reaches a dead end.
But this is literally the end of the entire pathway.
So there's nothing more off of here,
you reach the dead end with two rocks,
you'll notice it's the only one with two rocks, all the other ones have multiple rocks.
You make sort of a left
and you look for a pair of two trees and
BAM!
You got all the pages!
And that's how you do!
And then you let Chica come up
and give you a big ol' victory hug...
'cause she's a beaut'
and you love her to pieces
and she's gonna love me to pieces in just a hot second, here.
*sarcastic* AAAAAAHHH!!!
*Loud, distorted noise*
And then you beat the game.
So, that is how you beat Chica, and that is the special secret behind 'The Joy Of Creation'.
Easy-peasy-lemon-squeasy.
Right? Great.
So...
Oh man...
I--I don't even know anymore.
I've had such a time,
trying to get this to work!
And, MAAAAN oh man.
(Popping sounds from mouth)
I..
*sigh*
I'm gonna go relax, and then get you guys a second video.
That's what I owe you, and that's what I'm gonna get you.
Once again, I'm very sorry for the delay.
I have been absolutely slammed...
I've been losing sleep like every night.
I'm not trying to make excuses,
I'm just trying to paint the picture of why
things have been off-schedule,
with me going last minute to the wedding,
which I didn't even know I was gonna go to
until Friday, and I left Saturday, so...
Man, it's been a time, but I am working hard to get these videos to you guys,
I promise it'll be back on schedule soon.
I have just been going out of my mind..
with work.
But it's all for you guys, and I'm happy to do it.
*Horror outro fades in*
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you
in the next video.
Buh--bye!
*Haunted outro*
(Top video)
... ask your parents before watching this series
Because it's gonna get loud, crude, and offensively rude.
(Bottom video) BLRLBPH BLRLBPH
My hands are tingling
I can't feel my face anymore
I think everything gone and numb